i want to um
play a couple of clips for you
of a man
appearing thrilled
that
nancy pelosi has covered
this is this is really disgusting stuff
uh back during the late
period the late era the late stages of
the trump administration
you had people like don jr and others
saying democrats are taking pleasure
in people getting covered and dying of
covet and of course it wasn't true
there were it just wasn't true it wasn't
happening it wasn't happening
but i'm gonna play a clip for you now of
trump speaking somewhere or who even
knows
uh where he really seems to be taking
pleasure in playing very coy with nancy
pelosi testing positive for covid nancy
pelosi is 82 years old hopefully she's
well protected from the vaccine i've not
seen an update as to how she's doing
over the last 48 hours but hopefully
she's improving
um and here's trump kind of goading the
crowd with we want her to get well right
right and you can tell exactly what he's
doing here
[Applause]
by the way
lock her up
again the people that say they're for
law and order say skip due process don't
charge her don't try her
she's not even being investigated for
anything just lock her up that's not law
and order guys
[Applause]
okay now we're having trouble with the
video let's see if we can get the video
back here uh okay
uh technical issues plaguing us today
okay let's get back to it here
[Applause]
so trump says we want her to get well
right everybody want her to get well and
the crowd says no
[Applause]
you know
nancy pelosi is in charge of capital
security does anybody know that
so so uh trump really seems shaken up
there by uh by by nancy pelosi
uh
having coronavirus and then here's just
one other really weird clip from this
event i think you're probably more aware
of what's called the china virus
they released the china virus so after
years after years
of
no evidence that china released anything
and guys if they did i want to know
investigate as i i've never been one of
these people that says it's racist to
ask the question
if you get the if the first cases are in
country a
you look at country a and say well what
happened there but there's no evidence
that china released anything but it
doesn't matter trump keeps alluding to
that
from by the way where the hell did that
word come from
they had all sorts of things the only
thing that he wanted to mention was the
name china okay so continuing
uh just everything everything bizarre
about this event and you know it we
continue as i've said before the level
of projection from these folks is wild
they say look at this the other side is
doing that they're probably doing it
themselves hillary with uh sensitive
information
private email servers
records keeping
they're going to rob they're going to
try to steal the election well they they
tried to steal the election even though
uh trump lost
uh and with all we they want people to
die of covid you guys are the guys who
seem to laugh
whenever a democrat gets it whenever a
prominent democrat gets it these are
these are disgusting people
and um they are
everything that they accuse the left of
doing they actually are themselves it's
vile to see
if you're looking for a therapist or
seeking treatment for mental health or
substance abuse check out compassionate
care compassionate care is a medical
practice offering
mental health treatment that's
affordable and remote
in the comfort of your home
compassionate care offers remote talk
therapy to patients nationwide you can
establish a meaningful long-term
relationship without having to drive to
an office for every appointment
psychiatry services are available
remotely to patients in pennsylvania and
new york
compassionate care offers medication
assisted treatment for opioid or alcohol
addiction with the medications
buprenorphine and naltrexone available
in pennsylvania new york and delaware
compassionate care does not require
insurance they're a small independent
practice they support the david pakman
show and you can support them and
they're ready to talk to you get a free
consultation by calling 855 208
2408 or go to
caredrs.com the link is down below